and texas governor greg abbott tweeting
out this solution texas can do this our
producers can easily produce
that oil if your administration will
just stay out of the way
all right austin what are the goal what
the whole point
of uh to extricate ourselves from
foreign wars you should agree with me is
energy independence when we reach energy
independence we don't have to we don't
have to kiss the ring of opec and we can
live our lives cheaply and cleaner and
what does joe dewey's reversing it no i
i think that's confused exactly
this year this year production
from of oil in the u.s
is going to average over 11 million
barrels a day for the year it's likely
going to be in the top three oil
production years of all times in the
beginning opec he's not begging opec
he's doing what president trump did in
2019 what president bush did before that
president clinton before that which is
as you know there are a lot of there's a
lot of disputes within opec during the
pandemic some of the countries tried to
cut back production because they wanted
they thought the price is getting too
low and so the u.s president puts
pressure on opec to try to give weight
to the opec members that want to
increase the the amount of production
and refining
i do think politically it's a tough spot
whenever the price of gas goes up
that people look and they say ah this is
the president's fault but the argument
that the reason the price of gas is high
is because of u.s policy that's just not
correct the main thing that's happening
is the economy has come booming back
faster than people thought it would and
so we have restrictions of supply and
the demand is too high brian he killed a
pipeline
right
that cost thousands of jobs but he
killed the pipeline and again
it doesn't make sense to me i mean this
seems a little bit muddled to kill a
pipeline and then ask for help and
here's what's unbelievable the
difference between president bush and
president clinton and others who said
hey guys uh start pumping more let's
bring the price down with the supply up
is that you just had a guy two days
prior right around electric car and go
soon we're going to make uh uh the oil
the combustion engine old news and by
the way i need some help doing that and
if you go to texas where they have a lot
of leases in new mexico they're no
longer allowed to drill on private land
and almost all of new mexico excuse me
is federal land they have destroyed that
industry and for the very for the very
optics at the very least austin if you
say that we are drilling at the same
rate um i haven't checked the the barrel
numbers today but i heard a lot of
crashing it seemed like a lot of barrels
as they loading them on trucks and boats
but uh i'm just saying for the most part
you have no right to talk to opec two
days after you told everybody that oil
and gas are destroying the world he's an
enemy of fossil fuels now he's asking
for a favor that's a great point martha
what do you think
you know i think that it changed the
tone dramatically when you stop giving
federal leases for natural gas
exploration when you shut down a
pipeline you're sending the message to
oil producing countries that they're now
back in the in the driver's seat again
and that's something that had changed we
had uh we had reached energy
independence which was an extraordinary
achievement to not be reliant on foreign
sources or to be one of the largest
energy producers in the entire world put
us in a different position and it was
clear to other countries that we were
determined to continue down that road to
find our own sources of drilling to
expand pipeline availability for this
country and that message has reversed
that message is no longer
where people view the american pers the
american approach to to energy
degan you were hot on this story
yesterday tell me where austin is wrong
well everything that comes out of his
mouth is wrong um no i'm just i'm just
kidding but uh so just give bear with me
so the why a white house official said
that we're going to be
we're going to push forward with our
ambitious climate agenda but we're also
going to uh try to stop this temporary
surge in gas prices by begging opec to
produce more this perfectly illustrates
how fake and fugazi
that their green energy policy is it is
d-u-m-b moronical for them to do this
and here's why
you're discouraging production here but
then you're encouraging it elsewhere and
that serves zero purpose in fighting
climate change or it's called global
warming because we're talking about the
globe we're talking about the world so
wherever a barrel of oil is produced or
consumed is irrelevant wherever that oil
derrick is whether that that tailpipe is
is totally irrelevant if your rationale
is to fight global warming and to fight
climate change just like the world you
this this maneuver has zero impact on
the total global fossil fuel production
or consumption okay that's why that is
let's remember that is true you promote
electric cars
there's less demand for oil but that
doesn't raise the price of oil that
reduces the price of oil that's the
essence of the argument for the green
revolution so you're going to promote
you're going to promote electric
vehicles and you're going to try and
reduce fracking and the production of
natural gas in this country which is
used to produce the very electricity
that you need to charge these these cars
and by the way i i could belch
a better
energy policy than this administration
[Laughter]
you know it's it also who really
benefits from our green energy policy
china
yep because they're good they're they're
the ones that are gonna be selling the
solar panels we're better off we're
better off producing oil here and
natural gas because again they pre they
admit more um pollution to produce the
same amount of fuel or to transport the
same amount of fuel again where's that
canadian oil going that would have come
to the united states on the keystone
axle pipeline it's going to go on ships
to china china building enough electric
um power plants uh to put like
coal-fired power plants excuse me to
power all of germany that's pollution
for you all right
as well real quick is there a free
market way is there a free market way to
get electric cars those greens it's fox
and france this isn't fox and french i
got to go to bridge there was a free
market way to go green people would do
it yeah you do it i would you raise gas
prices your tax gas price is five
dollars a gallon and you make it so
expensive that people are forced to buy
electricity